اتقون انا وابويا كنا قاعدين في البيت كون
يوم السبت يوم السبت
3012 2023 مسكون انا وابويا وقونا وصلحو
في اعينا وخلونا عانين وطلعنا طلعنا جبال
وطلعنا خبصنا على جزاز وخب على حجار وقعدو
على ركبنا وس كل واحد قول انت حماس وانت
حماس فينا
خلب في الدبش تبع السلاح يجي ينسل فينا
د ابويا
في فتره السج ز اقعد على ركبك ارفع ايديك
تكيش مع حدا جيب البطانيه تغطى في
البطانيه واحده يسمونا من الساعه 7 الصبح
نجيب البطانيات لا الساعه 10 في الليل
واحنا بدون بطانيه فيين السقعه تم
اعتقالنا من مدرسه عون الحرشان الثانويه
للبنين للبنات في مشروع بيت لاهيه يوم
الاحد
101 تم مداهمه مدرسه عون
الحرتاني بالجراف الدبابه حاصرونا بعد
العصر زعق علينا اطلعوا مادون سن
56 من الرجال عراه بس بالملابس الداخليه
اللي هو الكلوت كان ظروف الاعتقال ظروف
صعبه جدا وهانم وهين مهينه بالدرجه الاولى
كان القصد منها اهانه الشعب الفلسطيني
بدايه من تعريت وخروجنا
بالكلتات الى الضرب الضرب
والسحق والتخبيط عليه وبهدلت
ونعت بجميع الالفاظ كان هدفهم بس ضرب
واهانه
اخذونا على البحر
وبتنا بالبكسر والشبا على البحر بعدين
اخذونا على مكان ثاني وضلينا لثاني يوم
تحت المطر والسقعه وبعد هيك اخذونا على
معتقل نقل كله طبعا في كل الوقت كنا تعي
عينينا مغمي ومكلش ايدينا ورا ظهرنا لما
افرجوا عنا 30 يوم قضيت في السجن لما
افرجوا عنا ومرنا على المعبر كرم ابو سالم
فكوا عن عينينا وقنا روحوا امشوا يلا
هلقيت بتجاه وتطلعو وراكم 30 يوم بتاكل
وبتشرب واديك مغمضه بتخش الحمام تلط حاجتك
وانت كمان مغمض عينيك واندك مكثفات
بالكلبشات احنا كنا ننام على بطانيه واحده
وفرشه زيها زي الحصيله زي البطانيه فيش
غيرها وبركسات ما فيش مش حطان شبك محطوط
ومحطوط عليه جين كانع ماساوي جدا جدا جدا
واي واحد لو بس همسه واحيانا بدون سبب
وبدون سبب يطلعونا بعين السقعه حونا
البطانيات طبعا البطانيات ما كانتش تدفي
ابدا السقعه ما فيش
مخدات النبيات الفش كانت 2 سن اقل من 2 سم
على الاسفلت في عزين سكعه الليل طويل كان
معاد النوم فيش نوم الا خ اقل من خمس
ساعات نام الساعه 11 في الليل احنا كان في
واحد معنا اسمه محمد عبدو يوميا كانت تجي
حاله بلبس كهرباء كان يظله يتشنج وكانوا
يضحكوا عليه الجنود كان يضحكوا عليه و
بتشنج هو بتشنج وبتلف حوالينا وبيبكي وبعص
على حاله كان يضحكوا عليه